buckle up welcome to Hannity let me give
you a quick headline the details will
follow nobody else will report the
Muller witch-hunt is completely over it
is done nobody listened to the Attorney
General and yeah the Attorney General
admitted today everything we've reported
the last two years full criminal
investigations are now just beginning
imagine that a talk-show host is Right
and so many in the fake news industry
are wrong we'll get to all of it but
first breaking just moments ago the
Attorney General bar will not head back
to Happ Capitol Hill tomorrow to be
grilled by Jerry Nadler lawyers because
he's too weak to question them himself
and tonight of course predictably more
breathless hysteria selective moral
outrage from the left they are
desperately trying to revive what is now
a dead fake phony narrative that's
finished they are wrong they were wrong
they lied to the American people they
continued to lie to the American people
they perpetrated a hoax
they push conspiracy theories they've
lost an operation crossfire hurricane is
now turned into operation boomerang we
will have full coverage of our bar
horowitz uber are about to up end the
corrupt actors in the deep state those
that abuse power they will bring equal
justice and equal application of our
laws to the American people it seems
tonight finally the Constitution and the
rule of law will be followed also
tonight we have a major breaking news
report brand-new from John Solomon
surrounding Bruce and Nellie or who may
soon be in serious legal trouble yeah I
think we predicted that too but the
mulher witch hunt is over let nobody
else fully they can talk about it til
the cows come home they can sit go home
and their heads can spin around like
Linda Blair and the Exorcist they can
projectile vomit this green stuff it's
not going to change the truth and the
second part of that is what we have
Dillinger diligently reported night
after night after night
for two years on this program our
ensemble cast I can't name everybody
there's not a lot of us what talk radio
Mark Levin and Rush Limbaugh and a few
others you know here on the channel like
Laura and Tucker and Fox and Friends
we've all been right so many others have
gotten it dead wrong they missed the
biggest story in their lifetime and we
can confirm tonight the criminal
investigations are in fact underway in a
major way
that is the headline the biggest
headline to come out of today and I
promise you no one else will report it
but not according to the Democratic and
media mob you know the ones that are
full of rage and psychotic hatred that
you know borders on all things Trump
Trump they're obsessing about bars
contentious hearing on Capitol Hill
which could have well basically been
wrapped up in about two minutes after
these important questions this is the
this is the money moment if you will
Lindsey Graham it says it all it
confirms what I just told you take a
look
do you share my concerns about the FISA
warrant process yes
do you share my concerns about the
counterintelligence investigation how
was opened and why it was opened yes you
share my concerns that the professional
lack of professionalism in the Clinton
email investigations something we should
all look at yes do you expect to change
your mind about the bottom line
conclusions of the Moller report no do
you think the president's campaign in
2016 was thoroughly looked at in terms
of whether or not they colluded with the
Russians yes and the answer is no
according to Bob Muller that's right he
couldn't decide about obstruction you
did is that correct that's right you
feel good about your decision absolutely
there you go no collusion no obstruction
and as we said the biggest headline that
no one of the media mob will ever tell
you is how the Attorney General has
confirmed today
he is investigating FISA abuse illicit
spying Clinton's rigged investigation
Clinton's collusion with her dirty
dossier the dirty dossier Ukrainian
collusion and so much more am i right
that is only beginning today and there's
so much there will be a cascade an
avalanche of information we're gonna get
to Lindsey Graham he'll join us in a
moment but for nearly 24 hours the
predictable media mob is totally
completely apoplectic apoplectic about a
new report from The Washington Post The
New York Times last night just hours
prior to bars highly anticipated hearing
these two far-left media propaganda
outlet slide again conveniently granted
access to a leaked letter from team
Muller to the Attorney General's Office
that expressed frustration over how Barr
initially summarized the report
Washington Post headline Muller
complained that bars letter did not
capture the context the entirety of the
Trump probe but within their own
reporting way underneath the headline
they actually contradicted their own
headline and the actual truth emerged
according to a DOJ spokesperson now
confirmed by the Attorney General
himself the special counsel emphasized
nothing zero in the Attorney General's
four-page March 24th letter was
inaccurate or misleading nothing but he
expressed frustration over the lack of
context oh and the resulting media
coverage regarding the special counsels
obstruction analysis
oh he's criticizing the media to
something Muller and I have in common is
this how Attorney General bar responded
earlier today let's go to the videotape
I said Bob what's with the letter you
know why don't you just pick up the
phone and call me if there's an issue
and he said that they were concerned
about the way the media was playing this
and felt that it was important to get
out the summaries which they felt would
put their work and
per context and avoid some of the
confusion that was emerging I asked him
if he felt that my letter was misleading
or inaccurate and he said no that oh so
according to Muller
it's the Attorney General's job to shape
how the media reports the story really
Bob now Barr followed up with the shot
at Miller's band of democratic donors he
appointed even the guy that was at
Hillary's victory party Muller's pit
bull Andrew Weissman with an atrocious
track record and of course that included
the Hillary Clinton attorney as it
relates to the Clinton Foundation take a
look the letters a bit snitty and I
think it was probably written by one of
his staff people did you make a
Memorandum of your conversation huh did
you make a memory I didn't need anyone
else
well I did anyone either you or anyone
on your staff memorialize your
conversation with Robert Muller yes who
did that there were notes taken of the
call may we have those notes no no I
love that all right it's taking a moment
to lay out the facts one more time
because well some people just need to
know where this is going we're trying to
educate them and it's hard they're so
entrenched in their own conspiracy
theories lies and their own mind I think
they actually believe their lies at this
point Muller found zero evidence that
anyone in the Trump campaign colluded
with Russia Muller did not make a
determination on obstruction the
Attorney General indicated these basic
findings in his letter on March 24th the
Department of Justice then determined
yes no obstruction took place and on
April 18th Barr released the full report
with only a few legally mandated
redactions because of a law supported by
Democrats following the star
investigation into Bill Clinton the
Attorney General he had no obligation
whatsoever to release any of the Muller
report that's the truth
that's the law these are the facts and
as Senator Ted Cruz pointed out earlier
today the complaints for the left
are totally absurd take a look so their
entire argument is general bar you
suppress the 19 pages that are entirely
public that we have that we can read
that they know every word of it
and their complaint is it was delayed a
few weeks and that was because of your
decision not to release the report
piecemeal but rather to release those 19
pages along with the entire 448 pages
produced by the Special Counsel yes if
that is their argument I have to say
that is an exceptionally weak argument
because if you're hiding something I'll
tell you right now general Bart you're
doing a very lousy job of hiding it all
right the media Mob Democratic mom they
don't care about facts they are driven
purely by an agenda by the way not
serving we we the people which is why
they are now smearing the Attorney
General even calling for him to be
impeached it won't go anywhere but take
a look anyway did the top law
enforcement official in the land mislead
Congress and the American people to
protect the president he was being
deceptive he knew he was there was an
ease with which Barr lied there are
contradictions there lies it's a
mystifying performance I think William
bars credibility is really in tatters an
attorney general who says Tuesday is
Monday and the Sun is the moon pure
political hackery
filled with lies full of
misrepresentations now I think there are
cases we can point to that will be
people will say or or perjury what we
have now is an attorney general who has
presented himself in a way that's not
really refutable anymore he is fully
obviously corrupted once again the media
is merely doing the bidding of their
allies in the new radical extreme
Democratic Socialist Party who are more
interested in grandstanding and rage
hating Trump and actually legislating on
behalf of you we the people take a look
I think history will judge you harshly
your credibility is undermined within
the department in this committee and
with the American people mr. Barr
you've seen have learned the pelo Buster
rules even better than senators do I
feel her answer was purposely misleading
and I think others do too now the
American people know that you are no
different from Rudy Giuliani or
Kellyanne Conway or any of the other
people who sacrifice their once decent
reputation for the grifter and liar who
sits in the Oval Office they've chosen
to be the president's lawyer and side
with him over the interests of the
American people now believe it or not
the fake news New York Times opinion
page was even more melodramatic where
James Comey well theatrically exclaiming
quote mr. Trump eats your soul and in
small bites I can't say it with a
straight face and the disgraced FBI
director who I said you have the right
to remain silent I suggest you use it
you're probably going to regret not
listening to me inferring that the
Attorney General is now soulless because
of President Trump perhaps it's time for
mr. Kohl me to finally wipe away his
tears from getting canned and realize
Jim the writing's on the wall trust me
you're in serious trouble tonight legal
jeopardy you abused your power I know
you think you're a super Patriot but a
lot of the FBI rank and file that I know
are embarrassed by what you did
he was the first FBI official to sign
off on that FISA warrant to spy on the
Trump campaign associate Carter Paige Oh
based on unverified uncorroborated
bought and paid for Clinton campaign op
research and the New York Times is
telling us may have been Russian
disinformation yes you signed off on
that he's the one that told
president-elect months later the dossier
was unverified it's not what he said in
the FISA warrant and he said it was
salacious months after he used the FISA
warrant did he lie in October he lie in
January of 2017 October 16 he was the
one who met with Susan Rice President
Obama crazy uncle Joe about the dossier
after the election Colby was the one who
leaked government memos about his
conversations with President Trump in
order to spur a Special Counsel
investigation that might be a crime
even though he was the one that declared
the president can fire an FBI director
for any or no reason at all he's the one
who surrounded himself with partisan
corrupt high-ranking officials who have
all either resign been fired or demoted
and now Comey is the one along with his
fellow deep state counterparts the
tables have now turned there's a new
sheriff in town his name is Bill Barr
and he confirmed today the investigation
into your actions the deep state spying
and all the other shenanigans that
happen rigging Hillary's investigation
trying to bludgeon a president duly
elected by we the people of the United
States we now know Horowitz's
investigation into Faiz abuse Hoover's
investigation into leaking more
investigations into Christopher Steele's
bought and paid for dossier paid for by
Hillary even Democratic collusion with
Ukraine they're trying to give us the
evidence other probes into rampant a
masking request carried out by Susan
Rice Samantha power in 2016 a 350
percent increase criminal referrals are
coming and here the United States of
America is supposed to be a democratic
republic based on the rule of law a
constitution it is not a bureaucratic
dictatorship where power is abused and
used by a select few unelected
unaccountable officials we give you
these tools because we trust you to
protect this country not use them and
turn them on the elected the the elected
president of the United States or the
American people this is now time we
either get this straight or say goodbye
USA because as Attorney General
Barr pointed out our criminal justice
system must never be used ever used as a
political weapon ever again right Jim
take a look the report is now in the
hands of the American people everyone
can decide for themselves there's an
election in 18 months that's very
democratic process but we're out of it
we have to stop using the criminal
justice process as a political weapon to
the extent there was overreach I don't
want to judge people's motives and come
to conclusion on that but to the extent
there was overreach what we have to be
concerned about is minoo a few people at
the top what get it getting it into
their heads that they know better than
the American people I've said it before
I will say it again Jim call me super
Patriot you have the right to remain
silent
I suggest you kind of listen maybe you
should stop writing op-eds start looking
in the mirror and maybe beef up your
legal team which by the way you cleverly
did with people that might have
testified against you is pretty smart
clever